what it means for writers in practical
terms is to stay open to the surprises
if you have a real idea in advance
exactly how it's gonna go that's gonna
lock you in and narrow you and and stunt
your creativity your character is going
to surprise you they're going to they're
going to do things that you never
thought they would do that they seem to
invent on their own to do and that's
what I was talking earlier about which
is this discovery and that the biggest
mistake you can make is to try to hole
it back if it runs off the the rails a
little bit that's great go with it and
see where that takes you and and be
surprised by be willing to be surprised
by where you end up with it because
otherwise it becomes intellectual it
becomes heady and we need our heads we
need our intellect but not in the movie
theater that's a place where we live
none in the head but hard in the belly
in the groin it's not about
understanding and knowing it's about
feeling it's about it's about passion
there's a really important place in our
lives for rational intelligent expansive
discourse and discussion but not in the
movies the movies is a safe place to
work out the lethal aspects of our
nature to go hog wild and buck naked and
crazy as a loon that's what art is for
you